HOUR.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: HIGH, WELCOME TO THIS
BUSY NEW SITE.
HE ONCE SAID, WHEN A WOMAN
ALLEGES SEXUAL ASSAULT, PRESUME
SHE IS TELLING THE TRUTH.
NEEDLESS TO SAY BIDEN HAS NOW
DONE A COMPLETE 180.
WILL CALL OUT THE RAMPANT
HYPOCRISY COMING UP, AND A NEW
ALLEGATION TONIGHT AS WE COME IN
THE AIR.
BIG NEWS ON THE DURHAM.
SIDNEY POWELL WILL JOIN US,
UPDATE US, ALSO TONIGHT, HOW IS
IT EVEN POSSIBLE TO FAIL OF
NEW YORK CITY AND STATE, THE
WORST CASE OF CORONAVIRUS, AND
THEY DID EVERYTHING WRONG.
RUDY GIULIANI WILL WEIGH IN, OUR
INVESTIGATION TONIGHT.
ALSO FRUSTRATED AMERICANS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, YOU’RE
SEEING IT EVERY WAY.
THEY ARE NOW BEGINNING TO REVOLT
AGAINST THE LOCKDOWN.
WAIT TILL WE SEE THE BEACHES IN
HUNTINGTON THIS WEEKEND IN
CALIFORNIA HAS 33 STATES ARE NOW
IN THE PROCESS OF LIFTING
RESTRICTIONS AND OPENING UP, AND
AT LEAST ONE PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
LEAGUE IS DAYS AWAY FROM
RETURNING TO ACTION.
THERE IS HOPE THEY ARE.
WE’LL HAVE MORE IN JUST MOMENTS.
FIRST WE TURN TO OUR TOP STORY,
THE HYPOCRISY, THE SEAT THAT IS
MODERN EXTREME DEMOCRATIC
RADICAL SOCIALIST PARTY.
HE IGNORED SEXUAL ASSAULT
ALLEGATIONS LEVIED AGAINST HIM
BY A FORMER STAFFER.
HER NAME IS TARA READE, TOO
GRAPHIC TO REPEAT ON TELEVISION.
WE WON’T DO IT.
TOP GRANT DEMOCRATS HAVE TRIED
TO GIVE BIDEN COVER WITH GLOWING
ENDORSEMENTS, THE MOB, THE
MEDIA, THEY ASKED THEM NOT ONE
SINGLE QUESTION ABOUT THE REID
ALLEGATION.
IT THE BELIEVERS WERE NOWHERE TO
BE FOUND, AND AFTER A MOUNTAIN
OF CORROBORATING EVIDENCE,
SURROUNDING HER ALLEGATION, THE
MEDIA WAS GUILTY DIDN’T COVERING
THE STORY, AND BIDEN WAS FINALLY
FORCED TO ANSWER SERIOUS
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ACCUSATIONS.
I THINK MIKA DID A GOOD JOB,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TWO YEARS YOUR WORDS, MAY WE
NOT START OFF WITH THE
PRESUMPTION THAT THE ESSENCE OF
WHAT SHE’S TALKING ABOUT ISRAEL.
SHE SAID YOU SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
HER.
>> FROM THE VERY BEGINNING, I’VE
SAID BELIEVING WOMEN MEANS
TAKING THE WOMEN’S CLAIM
SERIOUSLY.
WHEN SHE STEPS FORWARD, AND THEN
INFECT IT.
LOOK INTO IT.
THAT’S TRUE, IN THIS CASE AS
WELL.
WOMEN HAVE A RIGHT TO BE HEARD,
AND TO INVESTIGATE THE
PRINCIPLES THEY MAKE.
IN EVERY CASE, THE TRUTH IS WHAT
MATTERS.
IN THIS CASE, THE TRUTH IS, THE
CLAIMS ARE FALSE.
>> Sean: ARE THE LEFT NOW
GOING TO TREAT FIGHT IN THE WAY
THEY TREATED CAVANAGH?
WILL THEY SAY I BELIEVE HER THE
WAY THEY DID WITH THE CAVANAUGH
ACCUSERS?
EVEN THOUGH THEY DIDN’T HAVE
HALF THE CORROBORATION, THEY
DIDN’T HAVE ANY ACTUALLY.
NOR DO THEY HAVE A HAUNTING CALL
FROM THE MOTHER OF ANY OF THE
ACCUSERS.
ARE THEY GOING TO COMB THROUGH
BIDEN’S YEARBOOKS FROM
HIGH SCHOOL LIKE THEY DIDN’T
CAVANAUGH?
WILL THEY CALL FOR HIM TO STAND
DOWN FOR THE PARTY’S NOMINEES?
WILL THEY SAY I BELIEVE, IN THIS
CASE, TARA READE APPEARED THAT’S
WHAT THEY DEMANDED IN THE
CAVANAUGH CASE WITHOUT ANY
CORROBORATING EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER.
SHE HAS WITNESSES, SHE HAS HER
MOTHER’S PHONE CALL.
SHE FILED THE REPORT.
AT THE VERY LEAST, JOE HAS
NOTHING TO HIDE IT, AND HE WANTS
TO BE TRANSPARENT LIKE HE SAYS
HE DOES, HE CAN JUST RELEASE ALL
THE PERSONNEL FILES ON TARA
READE APPEARED AND NOW THERE
REPORTEDLY STORED UP WITH HIS
RECORDS.
NOW WE KNOW STAFF WAS IN THERE
ALREADY.
BIDEN, DOESN’T SEEM INTERESTED
IN THAT LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY.
SPEAKS VOLUMES, TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHY NOT APPROVE A SEARCH OF
HER NAME IN THOSE RECORDS?
>> PROVE A SEARCH OF HER NAME?
>> ANYTHING THAT MIGHT BE
RELATED TO TARA READE AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE RECORDS.
>> THERE IS NOTHING.
THEY WOULDN’T -- THEY’RE NOT
THERE.
I -- I DON’T UNDERSTAND THE
POINT YOU’RE TRYING TO MAKE.
>> NOTHING CLASSIFIED, I’M JUST
ASKING, WHY NOT DO A SEARCH FOR
TARA READE’S NAME AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE RECORDS?
>> WHO DOES THAT SEARCH?
>> HE SEEMS LIKE HE’S HIDING
SOMETHING OR MALFUNCTIONING AS
USUAL.
WE ALL KNOW HE’S NOT WORKING
WITH A FASTBALL OR EVEN A CURVE.
I DON’T THINK IT’S A SOFT PITCH
AT THIS POINT FOR THAT MATTER.
IT’S ACTUALLY REALLY HARD TO
WATCH, BUT WHEN YOU REMEMBER AS
THEY POINTED OUT A FEW MONTHS
AGO, HE WAS PROMOTING HIMSELF AS
A CHAMPION OF ALL VICTIMS.
RAMPANT HYPOCRISY, JUST LIKE
WITH SQUID AND PRO" AND
>> THE WOMAN SHOULD BE GIVEN
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT AND NOT BE
ABUSED AGAIN BY THE SYSTEM.
>> WOMEN DON’T REPORT IT, THEY
DON’T
>> WOMEN SHOULD BE LIVED.
NO MAN HAS A RIGHT TO LAY A HAND
ON THE WOMAN NO MATTER WHAT SHE
IS WEARING AND WHAT SHE DOES,
WHO SHE IS.
>> UNLESS YOU AFFIRMATIVELY SAY
IT, ANYBODY WHO ENGAGES IN THE
BEHAVIOR IS COMMITTING A CRIME.
SO MUCH HAS CHANGED ABOUT THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS THE PRESSURE
ON WOMEN.
I LEARNED A LOT AS WELL TOO.
>> Sean: IT’S A CLASS A HAVE A
RECORD, WHAT HAPPENED, JOE, YOU
KNOW LONGER BELIEVE WOMEN SHOULD
BE GIVEN THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT AND NOTES YOU ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THIS.
WHAT ABOUT THE ALLEGATIONS, AND
WHAT ABOUT THE ENDLESS STREAM OF
REPEAT FOOTAGE OF YOU YOU KNOW
GETTING WAY TOO CLOSE TO JUST
ABOUT EVERY FEMALE YOU CAN
INCITE.
IS THIS REALLY THE CHAMPION FOR
WOMEN THAT DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE
ONE THEY’RE GOING TO DOMINATE,
REALLY?
IT TURNS OUT MOST DEMOCRATS
DON’T REALLY SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
THE ISSUE BECAUSE IF THEY DID
THEY WILL TAKE OUR POSITION
WHICH IS THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE AND TAKE IT SERIOUSLY
AND LOOKING AT THE FACTS AND LET
PEOPLE DECIDE.
THAT’S THE WAY IT WORKS IN
SOCIETY BUT, IF YOU’RE
REPUBLICAN AND CONSERVATIVE, I
BELIEVE OR YOU’RE A DEMOCRAT,
SILENCE.
WE ARE USING IT AS A POLITICAL
WEAPON IN THE CAVANAGH CASE AND
AGAINST TRUMP AND THE HYPOCRISY
PROBABLY HAS NOT BEEN WORSE THAN
THIS.
IT TAKE A LOOK.
OF >> I BELIEVE IT, AND HE SHONE
SO CLEARLY HE DOES NOT HAVE THE
TEMPERATURE MEANT OR THE
CREDIBILITY TO SERVE ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
THE COURAGE SHE SHOWED WAS
REMARKABLE AND THE TESTIMONY WAS
COMPELLING AND INCREDIBLE.
I BELIEVE HIM.
>> Sean:NOT ONLY WOMEN WHO REALL
FORWARD NEED TO BE HEARD, BUT
THEY NEED TO BE BELIEVED.
>> I BELIEVE DR. FLORIDA, I
BELIEVE THE SURVIVOR HERE HAS
EVERY REASON TO BELIEVE HER.
I BELIEVE PROFESSOR FORD, I
THINK SHE’S CREDIBLE.
>> Sean: NANCY PELOSI, GOING
THERE AND TODAY WE REACHED OUT
TO WELL DOZENS OF DEMOCRATIC I
BELIEVE LAWMAKERS FOR A RESPONSE
AND NOT ONE PERSON HAD ANYTHING
SUPPORTIVE TO SAY ABOUT TARA
REID AND NOT A SINGLE ONE.
MOST DIDN’T EVEN GET BACK TO US
AND THE EYE BELIEVERS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
CONVENIENTLY EVAPORATED THIN AIR
AND TAKING AN BREATHTAKINGLY
HYPOCRISY.
IF YOUR DEMOCRAT OR LIBERAL YOU
GET A PASS, BUT IF YOU’RE
CONSERVATIVE YOU GET BLUDGEONED
TO DEATH AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE WITH PELOSI AND LET’S TAKE
A LOOK AT HER.
>> THE INVESTIGATION ON
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH, THE
ALLEGATION CAME OUT ON HIM.
>> LET ME JUST SAY, I RESPECT
YOUR QUESTION AND I DON’T NEED A
LECTURE OR A SPEECH.
WE ARE HERE TO SHOW OUR
SOLIDARITY, WE ARE HERE TO SHOW
OUR RESPECT FOR ALL WOMEN WHO
HAVE A CASE WHO HAVE RESPECTED
THAT THE DUE PROCESS.
>> THERE’S A LOT OF EXCITEMENT
AROUND THE IDEA.
BECAUSE THE ALLEGATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE ARE ABOUT
OFFENSES THAT HAVE A LIFETIME
IMPACT.
THERE’S ALSO DUE PROCESS.
THE FACT THAT JOE BIDEN’S
JOE BIDEN.
INSTEAD OF ASKING QUESTIONS, THE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP FEARS THE
TRUTH.
>>>> THERE’S NEVER ANY RECORD OF
THIS, THERE WAS NEVER ANY RECORD
RECORD.
REALLY, THEY ARE SO AFRAID OF
THE TRUTH AND SO AFRAID OF WOMEN
TO A TRUTH THAT SHE MAY SELL.
>> Sean: A BREATHTAKING
GROUPTHINK HYPOCRISY,
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DOESN’T CARE
ABOUT POWER AND WE ARE
CONSISTENT HERE AND WE BELIEVE
IN THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE
AND THAT YOU’RE INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY BUT TAKEN
SERIOUSLY, SURE, IT’S IMPORTANT.
WORST PART, THE MOTHER, MEDIA,
ABSOLUTELY MAKE ASSISTING THEM
AS LATEST SEPTEMBER 2017.
"WASHINGTON POST" WHERE PLANNING
KAVANAUGH’S DEMISE AND ONE
HEADLINE READING "THE JUSTICE
FOR KAVANAUGH’S IMPEACHMENT IS
MOUNTING AND HERE’S HOW WE CAN
WORK."
AND HERE’S HOW THEY COVERED THE
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST BIDEN.
"THEY AMPLIFY THE QUESTION OF
THE BEHAVIOR AND WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN."
IF THEY WORKED WITH THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN TO REMOVE LANGUAGE
ABOUT BIDEN’S MISCONDUCT FROM
ONE OF THEIR ARTICLES.
WOW, HAND-IN-HAND, WORKING
TOGETHER AND NOW THE DEMOCRATS
PRETENDING TO BE A NEWS HOST
JUST SAID THAT THE ALLEGATIONS
WERE PART OF THE RIGHT WING
SMEAR CAMPAIGN.
REALLY?
WHEN IN DOUBT, BLAME THE
CONSERVATIVES.
>> THERE NOT RUNNING A
INTELLECTUALLY HONEST WEATHER
TARA DOMINIC DOMINGO MIKE TARA
READE WAS
BRUTALIZED.
>> Sean: FOR THE MOB THE
MEDIA, THE PARTNERS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY RUN
CONSPIRACY TV TELEVISION LET’S
BE HONEST.
POLITICS COMES FIRST INTO THEM
IT’S NOT ABOUT PRINCIPLE, NOT
ABOUT VICTIMS RIGHTS AND NOT
ABOUT DUE PROCESS WHERE THE
CONSTITUTION AND THEY DON’T SEEM
TO CARE ABOUT ANY OF THAT AND
THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE AND
THE ONLY THING THEY CARE ABOUT
HIS POWER AND WINNING AND THAT
SAID AND THE CONTROL OF THEIR
LIFE.
NOW, WE ARE 186 DAYS AWAY AND
YOU ARE THE ULTIMATE JURY, AND
YOU’VE GOT TO BE CLEAR.
YOU WILL DECIDE THE FATE OF THE
GREAT REPUBLIC OH AND BY THE